promis davor bayerische ponys hautnah
heute zu besuch bei den beutel burgen
wie leben sie was denken sie was sind
ihre geheimnisse erfahren sie es jetzt
exklusiv bei promis erworben
grüß gott scheint dass sie bei uns
vorbeischauen
wir sind gerade mitten in den proben für
unsere große europatournee und da machen
es so dass man bei den zugaben immer
alte evergreens spielen und diesmal zb
schützenliesel
[Musik]
dreimal hat es gekracht
einmal zweimal dreimal hat es gekracht
einmal träumst du dazu sagen weiß und
weiß ich habe jetzt ganz vergessen
noch drei mal hat weg gebracht drei mal
drei mal hat es gekracht ja ich aber
auch nicht leicht ja freilich davon
brauchen wir mögen ja auch ja ich hab
das lassen wir das verschieben
aber ich glaube ich kann es jetzt mal
lieber nicht sind mama das andere lied
das ist doch auch so toll
dies ist gute freunde ja es ist auch so
super gute freunde kann niemand trennen
würde freunde sind mietshaus das heißt
allein allein muss so gute freunde kann
niemand trennen
gute freunde sind nie allein zu haus des
gastes passt der winter vornehmen das
heißt schon zuhause mamas anders machen
wir das so jetzt musst du die erste
zeile und nicht macht den schluss dann
gibt es ja immer dass man schon hat okay
gute freunde tut niemand kenne es heißt
es dass trainer wie so trennen wieso
sind sie freuen die trennen desto
schmaler die sollen sich nicht trennen
ja und setzen sie wieder nicht drinnen
ja aber das ist die frage wo wollen sie
hin überhaupt sind das ist krank haben
die sängerinnen tut beliebt freuen die
tum irgendwohin rennen dabei die sagen
ja fußballer gesehen hat dies ist gehen
bei ihnen nicht auch wenn das knie
bekennt ich hab so mag